top five books that impacted you the
most like what what are some books that
uh where you when your kids ask you Dad
give me five books I should read what
would those five books be they probably
wouldn't be my book so I thought my kids
I don't think my kids have read any any
of my books look if you're on a desert
island and you only have one book what
book would you take probably you take
the Bible because the Bible has so many
things about human life and and the way
humans have gotten together over the
years and interacted with everybody uh
then the Bible is an unusual and book
when you think about it 75 of it is the
Old Testament
um 25 is the New Testament but in both
the Old and New Testament uh you know
there are a lot of a lot of wisdom in
there I just think that's probably one
book you would probably want to want to
have with you uh maybe one of your books
I don't know yeah I mean I want to know
what you're going to see if I'm on an
island I got the Bible that's pretty
good if I got the business books on an
island with no Market no technology I'm
screwed like I probably need a big book
that I can make some fire like give me
the biggest book of all time
what else would you say you've read a
lot I mean you I do read a lot of books
because I have programs where I
interview authors and I think to to an
interview author I generally like to
read the book so I'm just reading a
number of books now for interviews I'm
going to do I just did an interview the
day of of uh the man who led the raid on
uh Bill mcraven Bill LED them raid to
capture Osama Bin Laden he had a book
called South uh Sea Stories and
interviewing him it's incredible how we
caught Osama Bin Laden and how he and at
the time we caught him they didn't know
we actually had him and so what happened
was
um they had to take him out of his body
bag Admiral that's him he gave a speech
that was viral that's uh University of
Texas yeah make your bed you were saying
well what happened was they captured him
they put him in the body bag they bring
them back and they unzip the body bag
and they pull them out and say oh is
this Osama Bin Laden was beard looks
shorter than than they thought we
weren't sure they knew he was six foot
four but they didn't so they didn't have
a tape measure so they sold another
sailor there he said sailor how tall are
you six foot two come over here lie down
next to the sky oh you look like you're
two inches shorter so he called
President Obama president President
Obama and said uh like we think it's him
we haven't done the DNA test but I just
had a soldier or sailor lie down next to
him who was six foot two this guy looks
two inches bigger so I think it's him
and Obama said well wait a second you
had a 90 million dollar helicopter and
you didn't pick a ten dollar tape
measure with you why didn't you do that
and so when when he met with Obama in
the Oval Office later he Obama gave him
a tape measure that's a what a good
story right there what a good story
right there 90 million here's 10 bucks
go measure it next time instead of
putting a guy laying next to him what
else so we got two books so far give me
another one give me give me one that's
an evergreen one not one that was just
written like something you read where
you're like because look if there's
something that a lot of people wanted
like first of all everybody has to read
the book how to invest especially if you
want to get into the business because
you're learning from 30 different
people's philosophies right it's not
like you're learning from one person by
the one thing that was very interesting
is how everyone talked about Warren
Buffett like everybody edified him and
gave him a ton of credit everybody was
it's as if they're talking about would
you say he's the Michael Jordan of that
industry yes and the reason is this he
has averaged 20 a year for 60 years 60
years
not 20 a year for two years three years
60 years I mean that's incredible what
he's done as an investor nobody's quite
ever done that and now he's still doing
this when he's in his 90s early 90s so
that's incredible if you want to read a
book about him there are a lot of great
books and more books about it here but
Warren Buffett probably than Abraham
Lincoln if that's possible but I would
say uh the book called snowball was
probably the best one on Warren Buffett
really really good book uh Warren
Buffett hasn't really written his own
book in that that sense uh another book
I've
um you know read recently um
there's a man named Sid mukhiji who
wrote a book called uh the Emperor of
all maladies about cancer and it was a
really well written book it won the
Pulitzer Prize his first book on the
Pulitzer Prize here's a new book out
called the song of the cell his third
book the first book was on cancer second
book is on uh on genes third book is on
cells it's on New York Times bestseller
list right now
um I've just that's it
no that's the first one that one that
one uh won the Pulitzer Prize in his
first book which is pretty good the ring
your first book to win a Pulitzer Prize
then when he I just interviewed him on
it's called the song of the cell which
is his latest book and um I've just
interviewed another great author John
Meacham Meacham has a new book out at
the number one best bestseller on
Abraham Lincoln and uh you know more
books I've written about Abraham Lincoln
anybody other than Jesus Christ so it's
incredible and uh but he has a lot of
good insights in it I'm just finishing a
book uh that I'm interviewing the author
on Maggie Haberman who wrote a book
about uh Donald Trump it's a quite
interesting book on insights about
Donald Trump they're the infinite number
of Trump's books but this one is uh
she's covered him for the New York Times
for four years and it's a pretty
interesting book that's it confidence
man yeah I saw that one I saw that one
uh
I saw that one yeah why do you think
people are so enamored by this guy good
bad and ugly is it because he's like a
complicated personality very unusual
person I do know him I I met with him
you know when he was president a number
of times and uh I would say uh it's
unusual um unusual person usually people
become president United States have some
government back when he didn't have any
background in government so it was a
unusual situation so with all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red or
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks spread toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]